So yesterday was day one of the Republican
National Convention.
And I've been struggling since it ended at
11:00 p.m. Eastern last night to figure out
really how to cover it or even talk about
it.
And when people do in public what many of
last night's Republican speakers did at the
RNC, it would lead to a nine one one call
and sometimes a 72 hour psych hold.
I mean, that's how outrageous what we saw
last night was and in thinking how to cover
it.
It's sort of like, do I include a ton of clips?
Do I include just a few?
Do I cover every speaker or just the highlights?
Do I cover the broad strokes of what the convention
is doing versus the minutia of what each speaker
is saying?
And I don't really know the answer.
So I'll just give you a few of my thoughts
for today and then we'll see tomorrow how
we cover it.
The theme yesterday was Attack Joe Biden.
But a little more specifically, it was rich
people and trust fund kids telling us that
Democrats are being mean to capitalism and
that if Joe Biden gets elected, there is going
to be some kind of a Marxist revolution in
this country and all of a sudden the United
States will be a communist dystopia.
And on top of this, yesterday was riddled
with identity politics now.
It was riddled with the same identity politics
that Republicans claim to be against.
One of my takeaways from watching yesterday's
RNC is I'm not KROT barring being Hispanic
into nearly enough conversations.
If I knew yesterday every speaker who could
justify being anything other than a white
person mentioned it multiple times.
Don Junior's girlfriend, Kimberly Guilfoyle,
reminding us multiple times that she's Hispanic.
Nikki Haley, that she's, I believe, Native
American.
Tim Scott that he's black.
Vernon Jones.
That he's black.
I thought they were against identity politics,
but I guess maybe they're only against it
when it's Democrats.
But clearly, if I am to take a lesson from
Republicans and why would I?
But if I were to in any opportunity that I
have, I should be mentioning, by the way,
I'm Hispanic.
Did you know that when I thought about yesterday's
presentations in total, I thought back to
that bizarre time were in 2012 at the RNC.
Clint Eastwood spoke to a chair.
And that was nothing as embarrassing and humiliating
as that was for Clint Eastwood, whether he
recognized it or not.
And I think he set since said he regrets it.
That was nothing.
Eight years ago, compared to yesterday's first
day of the Republican National Convention,
it was really one of the most deeply dystopian
events.
And what made it more dystopian was the degree
to which Republican voters loved it.
I was looking on Twitter.
I was looking in some of the recesses and
cesspools of the pro Trump Internet, and people
were just enamored with what they saw.
So let's look at some clips.
Again, I've been debating how to cover this,
I think, for today.
I'm going to do one basically one wrap up
clip and then we'll do separate clips for
specific stories as needed.
So each day we'll have sort of like the main
wrap up.
And of course, I'm not going to be able to
get to everything if you don't like this way
of covering it.
Just let me know and I'll look at look at
something else.
It's hours and hours of stuff, so it's very
difficult to get to all of it.
Now, two of the most Pyongyang, North Korea
like propaganda speeches came from Donald
Trump's son, Don Junior.
And Don Junior's girlfriend, former Fox News
hostess Kimberly Guilfoyle, recently recovered,
of course, from Corona virus.
Now, I'm going to start with Kimberly Guilfoyle
because Kimberly Guilfoyle speech was the
absolutely most outrageous thing, not just
at last night's Republican National Convention,
but really at any rate of Republican National
Convention that I've covered or watched.
Just screaming uncontrollably seemed like
a crazy person.
And I'm not using that pejoratively sheet.
She seemed out of it.
She seemed ill.
Take a look at this first clip.
Ladies and gentlemen, leaders and fighters
of freedom and liberty and the American dream.
Best is yet to come.
And then just got ya.
Then just going fully fascistic.
This is the language of dictators who just
project onto others what they actually want
to do.
Take a look at this.
They want to destroy this country and everything
that we have fought for and hold dear.
They want to steal your liberty, your freedom.
They want to control what you see and think
and believe.
So that they can control how you live.
To enslave you to the weak, dependent liberal
victim ideology, to the point that you will
not recognize this country or yourself.
So this was outrageous.
I mean, it was you know, it.
You could analyze it five or six different
ways.
It was it mania.
Was it delusional?
Was it that she chose to play a character
and the character was bonkers?
I just don't know.
And then she was sort of almost matched in
a sort of different tone and tenor.
By Donald Trump Junior, her partner in full
propaganda mode, essentially saying, Embrace
the Dear Leader.
I mean, the shades of North Korean propaganda
yesterday couldn't be missed.
Take a look at Don Junior here.
Imagine the life you want to have.
One with a great job, a beautiful home, a
perfect family.
You can have it.
Imagine the country you want to live in, one
with true equal opportunity where hard work
pays off and justice is served with compassion
and without partiality.
You can have it.
Imagine a world where the evils of communism
and radical Islamic terrorism are not given
a chance to spread.
Where heroes are celebrated and the good guys
win.
You can have it.
That is the life.
That is the country.
That is the world that Donald Trump and the
Republican Party are after.
And yes, you can have it, because unlike Joe
Biden and the radical left Democrats, our
party is open to everyone.
Everything you want can be given to you by
Donald Trump and Donald Trump only.
But notice, it's not going to happen in four
years.
It's going to take Trump eight years to give
you everything.
Nobody else can do it.
And Trump also couldn't do it in four years,
which is why he needs another four to give
you all of these things.
Any time that you hear this, one man can give
you everything stuff.
And we heard it in 2016 when Trump would say
only I can fix it.
That's an authoritarian red flag.
And likewise, the projection was just off
the wall.
Kimberly Guilfoyle projecting on to Joe Biden
the authoritarianism which is actually the
hallmark of Donald Trump.
And then they brought out a Cuban-American
named Maximo Alvarez.
And as I've mentioned before on the program,
as a Hispanic American myself, remember, the
RNC has taught me anything.
It's I need to constantly talk about how I'm
Hispanic.
The only Latin American group in the United
States that has any significant amount of
conservatism is Cuban-Americans.
All other Latino groups are overwhelmingly
liberal in the United States.
They brought out a Cuban-American, Maximo
Alvarez, who equated Joe Biden to Fidel Castro,
if you can imagine.
Take a look.
Speaking to you today, because I have seen
people like this before.
I've seen movements like these before.
I've seen ideas like these before.
And I am here to tell you we cannot let them
take over our country.
I heard the promises of Fidel Castro, and
I can never forget all those who grew up around
me, who look like me, who suffered stars and
died because they believe those empty promises.
Now, anybody who has any connection to reality
would know that there is no similarity between
center left Joe Biden, who's been pulled a
little bit further to the left over the last
three months.
There's nothing linking him to Fidel Castro
nor to Venezuelan leaders Hugo Chavez or Nicolas
Maduro.
But the constant imagery yesterday linking
Biden to Venezuela, linking Biden to Cuba,
to socialism, to Marxism.
Meanwhile, the progressive left is disappointed
that Biden isn't really that progressive.
I mean, it's just a fantasy world that this
convention was based on.
Now, I don't want to give the next two people
too much attention because it's borderline
criminal that they're even part of the Republican
National Convention.
But the McCluskey's this is the couple from
St. Louis who brandished firearms at Black
Lives Matter protesters.
They were invited to speak.
This is a couple, their lawyers who are known
only for pointing long guns, or I think it
was one long gun and a handgun at protesters
ain't set in St. Louis a few weeks ago.
They spoke.
I'm only going to give you five seconds of
them.
They don't.
I'm not.
I'm just refusing to give you more.
Here is I believe it's Patricia McClosky,
the wife, saying that Joe Biden wants to end.
The suburbs to abolish the suburbs altogether
by ending single family home zoning.
It's really an indictment of everything that
these people were even speakers at the convention
and then finishing out the Joe Biden will
abolish stuff phase of our review.
Here is Natalie Harpe claiming that Joe Biden
would essentially abolish doctors.
People wouldn't be able to have doctors anymore
if Joe Biden were president.
God forbid.
The next four years would look like for in
Joe Biden's America.
China would control our drug production.
We'd be one step closer to government run
health care.
We wouldn't just be unable to keep our doctors.
We'd be lucky if we could see any doctor.
We would be lucky if we could see any doctor
under Joe Biden, says Natalie Harpe now.
There were many more speakers.
Quite frankly, I don't think I can tolerate
too much more.
But the themes were claimed that there was
no policy discussed at the DNC.
And then don't talk about any policy.
Disparage the DNC as being just about criticizing
Trump.
But then spend the entire time merely criticizing
Joe Biden as a Marxist and a communist.
And I'm truly questioning, number one, the
future of this country of 60 million people
see this and then vote for it in November.
And number two, whether I'm actually going
to be able to make it through three more days
of this garbage, I'm going to try.
But this was true.
I mean, it's it's this isn't healthy.
This is really bad.
This is very, very bad.
And then to top it off.
Here is my absolute favorite moment from day
one of the RNC.
Donald Trump staged these little conversations
with different.
At one point it was with workers.
At another point it was with former hostages.
The idea was to put Trump in front of people
and make him seem like a relatable, normal
guy.
And at one point, one of the workers that
was part of the group that Trump was speaking
to said, I'm a custodian at a school.
Trump doesn't know what a custodian is.
It's just the epitome of privilege where anybody
who went to public school or even to private
school and was just like enmeshed in what
was going on, you would know the custodian
cleans the school.
It's not like Trump maybe thinks a financial
custodian of assets or something.
The worker says, I'm a custodian, Trump says.
Oh, and what do you do?
As if, you know, I'm dropping everything because
this is so crazy.
Take a look at it about you.
I'm a custodian at the post offices.
What do you do exactly?
Clean up this mess and everybody's germs and
all that kind of shit that that world, that
profession will never be out of business.
You know that, right?
Just a microcosm of the entire Republican
National Convention.
Day one, rich people and trust fund babies
claiming to be all about workers and the middle
class and fear mongering that Joe Biden will
make us Marxist while knowing absolutely nothing
about the middle class and workers.
So tonight we go on to day two.
Everything is always scheduled but could change.
Tonight, it's Melania Trump, Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo, Senator Rand Paul, that
Covington kid, Nick Sandman, Eric Trump and
Tiffany Trump.
I will see you tonight, eight thirty p.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube
and Twitch.